- Whip!
Nae nae!
I have six grandchildren
and that is what I'm saying.
And I'm sticking to it.
- I am indeed a grandmother of one.
- I am a grandmother of 17.
I was thinking the twist, for me.
- Remember mashed potatoes?
Mashed potatoes.
- I used to be a closet dancer,
and so I would move to the music
whatever the music was.
You're going to pick up your right leg.
Whip.
And then nae nae is,
you're going to put your opposite hand up.
And you're going to go back, like this.
Yeah.
Kind of like in a snake-like motion.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, okay awesome.
- It's like riding a horse.
- You guys are awesome.
- Whip, whip
and then nae nae on the second one.
- Exactly, yeah.
- There's no nae nae in-between.
- No it's whip, whip.
Like you're falling.
But don't fall.
- Okay.
- Do you have any idea
why it's called nae nae?
So I could do it together with...
- Um, I don't know actually.
And you can kinda like,
put your own style on it.
Yeah, exactly.
- You already know what it is!
Doin' it wrong.
I'm going to do it in the
closet until I get better at it.
- I think it's great.
I think it's really fun.
I mean it's like line dancing
and that's really fun.
- I was thinking similar,
the Slop, the Madison,
I love a lot more than these steps.
- I think i'm going to
teach all the grandchildren.
- [Interviewer] Have you
ever heard of twerking?
- I have heard of twerking.
I think that the word twerking
comes from working your twat.